hello and welcome to a very special live
episode of trigonometry I'm Francis
Foster I'm Constantin kissen and our
guest today has been that making the
news for last couple of days Lawrence
Fox welcome to trigonometry hi guys nice
to see you again it's good to see you
mate we'll talk about you know the the
comments that you made the apology we'll
we'll give our take on it and all of
that we'll talk about the bigger picture
issues as well but the one thing first
of all I appreciate is that as we move
from being a YouTube channel to more of
a media organization and covering
different issues I'm actually really
pleased that you felt comfortable to
come here and talk to us when a lot of
other mainstream Publications wanted to
do an interview but not on the terms
that that are actually reasonable Etc so
thank you for being here and in that
Spirit the first thing I actually think
we should do just before we should also
mention that the people watching at home
can send questions to Lawrence on
YouTube super chats and paypals and we
will answer we'll do an interview then
we'll have a quick break and then we'll
answer your questions but Lawrence what
I wanted to say is I think quite often
whenever anything like this happens
there is not enough context to whatever
it is that's happened doesn't mean that
it excuses certain comments and you know
we'll get into all of that but the first
thing I wanted to do is actually explain
what happened so this has been a serious
of dominoes the first of which was our
friend Jeff Norco a brilliant comedian
he went on a show called politics live
um and there was a conversation with AA
Evans uh and a couple of other people
about male suicide we're going to play
that clip for you now so that you know
what's going on you role would Champion
issues such as reducing male suicide
would that be something you'd be in
favor of well what's interested about
that is the hostility it sometimes faces
whenever it comes up I saw a program
where there was like a feminist academic
and a lib Dem MP and they were so
hostile to this idea and I thought if
you if you flipped those things I.E that
is the biggest cause of death for men
under 50 is suicide men are less likely
to go to the doctors you know men are
less likely to maintain friendships if
that was for women we'd have to look at
well why is society making that happen
whereas with men the argument is often
why are they doing that to themselves so
I I'm not like totally wedded to the
idea but the hostility towards the idea
I find it instructive AA I think that it
feeds into the culture a little bit this
Minister for men argument like in my
mind I think there should be a minister
for mental health which would be
all-encompassing I mean you've got
something like 7 million children
waiting for prescriptions for mental
health at the moment it's a crisis
that's endemic throughout the country
not specific to men and I think you know
a lot of ministers kind of Bandy this
about to sort of I'm sorry but make an
enemy out of women I think not you and I
don't think your book don't I don't
accept that I don't think it is to make
an enemy if we looked like during Co men
were more literally more likely to die
from Co and I don't really want to cast
myself as as a menist or one of these
guys from manosphere cuz that's not who
I am but I do find it interesting that
sometimes the arguments tend to throw it
back but who was doing all the work
during Co you know a lot of the time if
you looked into people's households it
was the women who were taking on the
laundry the school the school care all
of that I'm disputing any of that what
I'm saying that there are specific
issues that men face that might warrant
specific attention I mean literally the
biggest killer of of men under 50 is
suicide that is an arresting statistic
and if that doesn't want specific
attention mental health is an umbrella
issue I have to say that it's also
because women are un successful that is
a lot of that is feeds into that
statistic but it feel it feels like it
just doesn't feel like you've got any
space for this idea that men might have
unique challenges that face them and the
problem is even as I'm saying this in my
mind it's like I've got out of the
violin and I don't want to be I don't
want to be I don't want to be this guy
because that's part of the problem is
because you're encouraged on one level
is men need to talk about their problems
more and then the moment you do it
you're like all right not not not quite
so often and not quite so loud so so
like you say the book is not the book is
more light-hearted than that but it
certainly you know goes around okay so
that was Jeff norcot on BBC politics
live and that then
sparked what happened afterwards which
was you going on Dam Wen shot and here
is this clip which is what you said
we're passward so I can say this um show
me a single self-respecting man that
would like to climb into bed with that
woman ever ever who wasn't an incel who
wasn't a cucked little incel that little
woman has been fed spoonfed oppression
day after day after day after day
starting with the LIE of the gender uh
uh wage Gap and she sat there and I'm
going like if I met you in a bar and
that was like sentence three chances of
me just walking away are just huge we
need powerful strong amazing women who
make great points for themselves we
don't need these sort of feminist 4.0
they're pathetic and embarrassing who'd
want to Shag that Lawrence well look she
sorry I'm just I'm just I'm just going
to provide a touch of balance from her
because she did actually respond to this
earlier today saying that she regretted
her comments but she didn't
apologize uh yes so so so there you
go and she's a very beautiful woman
Lawrence very beautiful there you go Al
I'm probably
I'm okay okay Lawrence so looking at
that clip in the cold brutal light of
day it doesn't look good mate does it
no no no um I
think I'd spoken to them earlier in the
day and um you know CU you have a pre
interview interview if you know what I
mean and they said we're going to do
this story and I I was slightly hoping
that they weren't going to do that story
because um I had had strong feelings
about it uh certainly the what I felt
was the littling of male mental health
and all of that sort of stuff and as the
context that Constantin has already
added and I thought there probably a
chance that I will go over the top here
because I'm emotional you know and I
spent 22 years acting so what when
you're an actor you're trained on
Instinct you're training to feel
Instinct and act jump on it because
that's how you
keep stories going and people suspend
their disbelief so that is my um it's
the way my brain works and also I'm
highly emotional as
so um when I listen back to it now I
just go it's just kind of crass it's
kind of thing you say in a pub MH people
do say in pubs you hear it all the time
stuff like that but the point is I I
should have really just attacked I think
I I think I was fair enough to make the
the point that I wanted to make which
was when you've got a misandrist fourth
wve feminist feminist who wants men to
be terrified and scared of women and who
tweets pictures of her saying I'm self
self self socially distancing from men
and and you know I'm wearing a mask to
protect myself from the most deadly
virus of all men I'm just a bit like it
stop and therefore what instead of
dismantling her ideas I just said I
can't think of a single man man who want
to Shag you I mean which self-respecting
man would want to Shag you um I was also
trying to be
funny big mistake um and
I you know I listen back to it and I
think yeah it's crass and crap and you
know and but I don't really if I'm truly
honest think it it's uh merited the I
mean wall to wall channel to channel
politician everyone media everyone um
condemnation especially when you see
half the stuff that has been said which
is infinitely worse and has pass without
problem well look I I agree with you on
that aspect of it I do think that the
entire thing has been blown out of all
proportion and now we'll get on to that
later in the interview but I would say
to your point about being an actor and I
understand if you are an actor you're
emotion you're an emotional person
because that is the nature of the
profession I've done some acting
training myself however Lawrence you're
now a political figure isn't it the role
of a polit political figure to be
measured to be reasonable to be
analytical it's not to go in with
emotion um no I think we need more
emotion in politics actually I think um
we we could deal with a lot more emotion
in politics rather than people just
nodding along to whatever they say I
think it I I would never want to uh I
perhaps need to harness my emotion but I
think emotion and Instinct are two of
the most powerful tricks and tools that
one has in the um in the Armory but yeah
uh 100% you're right I a who is AA Evans
M with all due respect to her I'd never
heard of her until two days ago I don't
know what she is or what she does for a
living I still don't know what she does
for a living um and I probably should
have not gone down to her level you know
and uh and as I've said you know I I've
I've apologized for the way I
spoke uh because it is it's not helpful
and it's uh it doesn't get across the
point which is the sentiment behind what
I spoke which is women like that women
who have that ideological
uh position of hyper feminism which is
sort of authoritarian rather than
egalitarian feminism and um and
missandry I'm my point was what man who
wants to build a life and build a a
great Union and a family of which this
country needs a lot because our because
our birth rates are so low would want if
if he was to marry a woman like that I'd
imagine he'd be giving himself a life
sentence of you you know hell Lawrence
when I saw that clip there was part of
me that thought did you have a few
drinks before that and then you think
and then you just went right screw this
I'm going to tell them what I think I'd
had a glass of wine at dinner yeah
definitely but I've not a few but you
know it's it's 9 it's not so much that
it's like 9:30 at night you're like
you're at the end of the day you're much
more kind of I've finished all my things
I can relax which is what you can't do
cuz it's television you shouldn't Rel
but you know I am reminded back of those
sort of shows like the word and all of
that stuff do you remember and we were
raised on that and also I spend a lot of
time listening to I think one of the
other things that affects the way I
speak sometimes is I spend a lot of time
listening to American podcasts so I'll
listen to like Megan Kelly a lot yeah
and she's sort of chatting away and
she's going I'm soing [__] him that's
why I don't care [__] him you know and
and I sort of you become influenced and
you forget that British Broadcasting is
about going yes um yes on the 9:00 news
we're going to talk about this and that
but um so yeah def I'm not making
excuses for myself it was crass poorly
um poorly
expressed deean which is wrong what's
point in doing that and it removed I
didn't get my point across which is what
I was there to do which was to get a
point there is a possibility that people
will only be hearing me through Fran's
microphone at the moment uh some people
will uh our critics will say we're doing
a very good impression GB in the early
days which is a fair comment we'll take
it um taking the piss hour look I I
think the reason I wanted to have you on
actually is that when I saw your
comments I just thought Lawrence this is
a silly thing to say it's offensive it's
you know crash and I didn't comment on
it a couple of days cuz I thought what
should have happened which is GB news
has an editorial code you've clearly
broken it you're probably going to get
sacked that is what should happen right
in this situation and that's it but I
think think what we've also seen is the
reaction it's just been insane from my
perspective and that isn't to to you
know I think your point is interesting
about podcasts in particular
because GB news is ofcom regulated it's
a British public broadcaster right and
that isn't the same as sitting even
sitting here with us yeah is
different um and do you think that maybe
you w't is is it that you sort of forgot
about it or is it that you actually
chafe against the restrictions that GB
news is operating under I've had a lot
of ofcom training uh by G news and I've
never up until Monday had a um complaint
that's been made and upheld against me
that that as Angelos who's walking
around throwing everyone under the bus
this morning has said you know I S close
to the wind I know what Angelos franos
the guy who um runs it the chief
executive yeah and um
I my thing is because of the way that
you know I am I can I'm recklessly free
in my expression in a lot of ways so
when someone says ofcom I just think oh
there's a bunch of Communists who want
to shut everyone up and silence people
and I don't really think about them so I
just think if you're telling the truth
if it's an opinion you're being asked
for then offer it you know and obviously
there there ones I offer an opinion
every single week and um about various
things you know they I occasionally
people shout in my ear and go you got to
have more balance push back and I'm like
that's good you do want balance and you
do want to push back but at the same
time yeah I think you get confused
between the areas from the pub chat to
the podcast to the ofcom regulated space
but it's not an excuse I'm I'm hired by
them I've got a well for about the next
20 minutes probably um I've got a you
know it is my responsibility to to do it
but I also think at the same time GB
news itself
calls itself the with free speech so
they possibly but they do have an
editorial chter and Charter says You
must respect people's opinions and
people right and we'd all agreed that
what you said about AA was disrespectful
yeah I don't think it's I I don't think
it's misogyny or anything like that I
think it's disrespectful I I think it
was I think the fact you know what I'll
tell you just as a someone who works
with words quite a lot if you'd said
shag her it would have been offensive
but I think shag that really took it to
a different level yeah well I wasn't
referring to her I wasn't itemizing her
as that what I was saying was this this
is the sort of person if you met someone
in a bar like that and actually I wasn't
talking about her at that point I was
saying if you met someone in a bar and
the third sentence in they started
telling you how much they hated men
who'd want to Shag that person I you
know so you could say her or you could
say if I just added the word person yeah
but what it came across as uh which I
completely understand and it's you know
again I'm not I'm holding my hands up
is it when who wants shag that like it's
some object so I can see that I that's
how a lot of people reive yeah yeah of
course they do but you know anyone who
is looking for and you know when I look
at it it sounds like that too but it
wasn't my attention yeah and look I
don't want to make this the grilling of
Lawrence Fox you can you can make it I I
don't want to because uh I think as I
said I think what you said was crash and
wrong and I also think the reaction to
it has been just insane to me it's like
a trap and we'll talk a little bit about
that is in the moment but you know there
was some debate internally here about
whether we should have you or not and
for us and for me and Francis it was it
was obvious that we should because I
think it's important to have these
discussions but you're a Christian and
we have some Christians who work here
who were like how does this reconcile
with Lawrence's Faith exactly you know I
haven't read the Bible cover to cover
but you know what I mean I don't know
talking about whether you chag someone
is in there no it's definitely not in
there
um along with he was without sin cast
the first stone and the fact that we're
all fallen so we are you know we're all
sinful we're all Fallen Jesus Christ
died for our sins we can't be perfect
all the time we're not perfect so we are
we are by our very definition fallen so
that's just an example of someone Fallen
being fallen in my book it doesn't
reconcile itself with my faith because
it's you know we're all created equal in
the eyes of God and actually you know
speak to any women I know they're up
they're upheld and um loved and
supported and honored as they should be
my problem is emotion it's like do not
belittle male suicide because I have
friends who have died for male suicide
and you don't see it
coming and I'm still angry about it
don't do that don't go it's a cultureal
issue
or you never see it in men because they
just
go and then they you know I'm lucky I'm
an emotional person and that is a
story and to belittle that is shameful
and disgusting actually and you know I
could make an argument now that I'm
riled up again to say people like that
are vile disgusting people but I can't
do that but I can make an argument to do
it because I don't want to be in that
world I would much rather be in the
forgiveness and Contrition world and cuz
that's where we're going to have to head
but to do that you know I've had to deal
with families that have have had this
take place and no one knew it was coming
so you do need to talk about men's
mental health and you don't need to poo
poo it in like talk about fing gender
pay Gap when someone's trying to make a
serious point so that I'm still enraged
about that I don't blame you by the way
I think in the interest of you know I
actually I'm so glad you you've
explained that part of it because
doesn't justify your comments but I
think what happened in that BBC politics
live thing we didn't play the full clip
by the end of it there was another woman
who jumped in and by the end of it Jeff
was like apologizing for sexual assault
against women when the entire
conversation was supposed to be about
male suicide and the demonization of men
in the media in advertising in Hollywood
it is happening and we all see it you
you have to be blind not to and I think
it's bad for men and for women
feminization of men that's what it is
it's it's this is my objection to the
fourth way of feminism if that's where
we are is is essentially of course we
want equality of course we want equality
and of course we don't want men going
I'm going to you know you don't want the
behaviors that have taken place in the
past you want women to have just as
active role in life as men do but this
wave is is it's it's
vengeful o of of us and actually you
know the amount of men in this world who
do wonderful and amazing things and
sacrifice hugely for women what we just
throw them under the bus and and put
them all in with the same thing and you
know it is as Jeff I mean Jeff is a much
much more measured person than me and
even he was starting to get like what
I'm feeling OG in tense about this
because the media narrative is bollocks
to men It's All About Women and
diversity and equity and inclusion and
it's like well do we get
included do our problems get included
this kills more people than any run
under 50 you know I've had people I've
known who've come back from the Gulf War
and have killed themselves you know so
not only have they gone along with 99%
of the other men to whether you agree
with the fighting or not they've gone to
represent Britain's interest overseas
and had people die in tanks that have
fallen off uh you know marshbanks and
sunk and listened to the last words of
their friends crying to the point where
you know as they're dying and comforting
each other then to go home and to take
their own lives I mean it's despicable
you you know that phrase sorry Franc
just one more question from me and then
you take over um you know the phrase the
medium is the message yeah do you I
wonder whether you know that you
mentioned you were trying to be funny
you were trying to be provocative as
late at night you've got a short amount
of time to make some kind of impact I
don't think anybody's ever heard the
argument that you've just made made by
you as eloquently as you've just put it
and I think is it possible that that
Medium where you've got a three minute
thing it just doesn't allow the depth
and the Nuance that having an hour like
this sitting down with people who
disagree with what you said but still
you know are interested in the the
broader conversation yeah that seems to
me to be just a completely different way
of having this discussion I never wanted
to do that 9:00 9:30 slot with Dan
because it's exactly clickbait it's just
clickbait they just you know they give
you the most provocative story and they
want Lawrence to come in and say
something provocative of which at this
on this occasion I went over line quite
substantially but that's what they kind
of want they want you to sail through
and it's just it's unhealthy I don't
think it's good for television in fact I
think um hourong television with four
breaks and five different stories is
crap actually and I I and as we've seen
with the massive Rising podcasting and
the success of podcasting you don't need
it so GB news are I admire what their
original Mission was to do and I and I
watch in horror I feel Dreadful because
a trap was set and the bait was
me and GB news ate the bait and that's
what happened but the trap's been
waiting there forever the Trap has been
waiting and all GB news had to do was
cancel one of their own and then GB news
are no longer name with free speech do
you know what I mean let's explore that
because what do you mean by that
Lawrence they want there the if you look
at the reaction to what's happened every
single media channel mhm from both sides
of the what I call the union party but
labor and conservative and every single
politician and media outlet has saying
the same thing shut them down well let's
play a clip of that uh we've got a clip
actually of Adam Bolton on news night he
was there along with several others
including a conservative MP and this is
what took place I watched it until it
was drawn attention to but I wasn't
surprised uh nonetheless I did ask
myself why these two people were on a
purportedly serious news station at all
bearing in mind that Mr won in other
areas is currently suspended from the
mail he's under investigation at the son
as well for his previous Behavior over
Al allegations that he denies denies and
and as far as uh Lawrence Fox is
concerned I think he now has a long
record of saying pretty extreme things
and in fact I was at a news meeting at
another broadcast today and saying well
you know would you still put Lawrence
Fox on television and the conclusion was
you probably wouldn't and both of them I
think have damaged themselves by doing
this and therefore we say well why was
GB news doing it and you know I have to
say I think the complaints have piled up
against GB news I think there is a
delicate and important broadcast ecology
in this country I think you know GB news
is trying to bust that ecology and
frankly what ofcom should do is shut it
down like it shut down uh
RT I mean shut down like shut down RT I
mean RT is the propaganda wing of the
Russian government anyway yeah so that's
worrying
because people will find what you said
dis stayful they may argue that it's
sexist fair enough but what you're going
to shut down an entire TV channel
because of words that are distasteful I
mean that is an overreaction to put it
mildly well I think the Clue the hint is
in the two things that I hear there are
broadcast
ecology now what is a broadcast ecology
for me in my overwhelming belief that
there's no the the the idea the we live
in a democratic country is not not true
anymore we we're living in a very soft
communist state in the UK at the moment
so the broadcast
ecology is parrot whatever the regime
want you to parot be it over coid be it
over um GB news be it over anything be
it over trans issues anything that or
cultural issues you know BLM all of
these things there is a broadcast
ecology that they fit in and that's the
narrative mostly peaceful riots etc etc
etc um so GB news's attempt to disrupt
that broadcast techology it was a very
healthy idea and it was its USP but the
second thing he said which and it just s
of comes out Rel he said I don't think
Lawrence Fox should just be allowed on
TV and it's like do you you do realize
what you're saying you're saying I think
that this person should be banned from
our broadcast ecology that we've created
for you and I think GB
news
would I know ofcom is a nightmare but
I've be I've been into that office which
is about the most toxic place you can
ever spend time in my view I find the
whole building just cuz it's full of
snakes who want to close whole thing
down from within anyway we're talking
about GB news about GB news and you go
into the office and it's just like oh
you need a shower when you leave and I'm
any in there five six hours a week um
and I've said to them every time I walk
in I've said you need to start pushing
back against this because ofcom are
going to kill you whether you like it or
not so and they're currently working on
a different model as well similar to you
know I think getting off I imagine they
will be booted off probably but they had
an opportunity yesterday they for to
turn around just go look I I thought
what Lawrence said was reprehensible and
appalling and went far beyond what GB
news did but
fundamentally we believe in the right to
free speech so we you know we utterly
condemn what he said but we utterly
defend his right to say it I mean that
would that's it's the it's the it's the
Free Speech version of of Martin Luther
King saying content of character not
color of skin hold on hold on you when
you became a presenter on GB news you
agreed to the editorial Charter yeah
that's true which you broke right well I
don't know if I broke it you definitely
did I mean I've I've read it it says You
must respect the opinions of others and
those people and we've already agreed
not to go over all ground but we'
already agreed your comments were
disrespectful to so you did break it
which is look people are going to break
rules and that happens so I I have to
say from where as an outside Observer I
I think your criticism of GB news is
unreasonable in this situation they have
to they have to suspend you no I'm I'm
not saying they suspend probably sack
you and and therefore how can they
defend your right to say it if they're
suspending you for it how can they do
that the the from their perspective
they're going we're regulated by ofcom
Lawrence has broken our rules he's
broken ofcom rules yeah so I think the
issue you're fighting against here is
that GB news is an ofcom regulated
broadcaster and not a YouTube channel
let's say right so they also but you
know just to again in
terms in terms of context I told them
exactly what I was going to say
including the word shag I said who want
to Shag that and they were giggling away
and they were giggling away right up
until the moment the mob came for them
so yes i' I've gone past their editorial
thing also by the way I'm totally happy
to get sacked no I know I know but I'm
saying your criticism is unfair it seems
to me well I I don't I think GB news are
what is the point in labeling yourself
the home of free speech if you're going
to cancel people for free speech it's an
oxymoron therefore if your business
model is to be the home of free speech
then either campaign to have ofcom
removed or do it online surely because
if you you can't it it ofcom have proven
that free speech is not celebrated in
this country we look at the whole point
of jub news existing in the media
landscape was because every single other
news channel was saying exactly the same
thing so GB news came on and the M the
media have looked at them and said we'll
get them somehow we'll get them someone
will do it and if it hadn't been me that
trod on the mine it would have been
someone else who trod on the mine at
some point you know and that's what
that's what would have happened but the
what scares me is the fact that um
everyone wants them shut down that's
what scares me now I think that
they should have been a bit bullier
about the whole thing if I'm honest I
said I think I think what they should
have done is instead of utterly
completely condemn me they should have
turned around they possibly phoned me
and said listen
you what on Earth was going on and I and
let and let me at least explain as I've
explained here what's going on and then
take a pause to work out what is their
position on this have you spoken to
anybody that no no one's called me at
all I was on my phone I was on my phone
and I you know when you get those news
things appear like Lawrence Fox SP from
GB news and I actually laughed because I
thought that's so funny that no one
would even send you a you know a message
or anything like that so yeah I mean it
is what it is I mean look to be fair to
GB news they are I mean it's a tough
situation to be it is a tough situation
because for context for people watching
from they've got an advertising boycott
against them so they're hemorrhaging
money they've got people pressuring them
they've got people criticizing them
they've got the entire media ecology
against them and all of a sudden this
Brad ecology broadcast ecology that's
the one right you know so in a way it is
understandable Lawrence yes no I'm not
I'm not going it's all their fault it's
all my I think we've gone through the I
think we've gone through the struggle
session of it's all my fault
look I hope there hasn't been a struggle
no no because I think look I I'm yeah
you know I just to me in my brain I just
find the whole idea of
ofcom stunningly ridiculous well this is
what I'm saying to you is you're blaming
GB news for being regulated yeah yeah I
think I think that's kind of what you're
fighting against and by the way just so
that it doesn't feel too much like a
struggle session particularly on the
broadcast ecology Point there's actually
a few videos that I want to play for
people to get a little bit of context
about what can happen on other channels
uh and what people do on other channels
and no one demands those channels are
shut down so we have a clip of the man
we just saw Adam Bolton uh this is how
he used to speak to staff when he was on
Sky News by the way uh he still works
for ruper Murdock it's having to go GB
news I wonder if that's a complete
accident anyway let's play this
clip yeah if if if Beth comes put her in
there and then she can go away I know I
know just put the [__] seat
in have you got have you got the grab
yeah yeah well she's going to come and
[__] sit here if she wants to be on
telly
has the great BJ been speaking yet no
are you going to attend well in
the past few
minutes uh Mr Johnson
arrived what the what the
[__] sit down there stop [__]
[Music]
around
yes well uh Beth is here uh you can see
Boris Johnson speech when it happens
around
best great respector of women that guy
yeah but I I actually defend him you do
because yeah he wasn't on air and if you
I mean God forbid what GB news have got
sto in the cupboard of things I've said
when we're not on air I can see why
you're defending him no I don't care
because I'm think he wasn't on air yeah
I'd much I'm much more interested in the
woman this morning who turned around oh
yesterday on timed radio in the middle
of the day and went Lawrence Fox is a
dick because I wonder is that the same
level of well right and actually perhaps
more to your point we have a clip from
Sky News talking about the Martin Basher
Affair who of course tricked Princess Di
and we don't even need to play it
because I think we we can retell the
story he tricked
using fraudulent documents Princess
Diana in to give an interview while
working at the BBC Russell Brand sax
gate happened while he was working at
the BBC I mean we could go further into
the history of BBC uh presenters
behavior on and off screen uh without
making this too uh too non
so all of that was wrong I think all the
people were reprimanded of the ones that
were you know available to be
reprimanded at the time but no nobody
called for the BBC to be shut down
Philip Scofield's Behavior didn't result
in ITV being shut down or anyone calling
for it to be shut down so the I think we
might have done M yeah no one was paying
attention to us exactly they are now so
my point is what I where I do agree with
you is there is clearly a politically
motivated campaign to shut down GB news
by let's be honest their Rivals yeah and
well the but also the establishment The
Establishment narrative so this um media
uh e ecosystem whatever the I've forgot
him now it called broadcast ecology um
that reaches out doesn't it because it's
a massive institution the BBC and uh
stuff like that it the broadcast ecology
reaches out into the cultural Ecology of
what is and isn't acceptable where the
over window sits within Society GB news
you're right I should separate out my um
criticism
GB news wanted to shift
that uh well to do its best to to
provide let's face it 51% of the
population with something to watch that
they might learn something from or agree
with and JB news often listens to its
audience it doesn't tell them what to
think it doesn't use that broadcast
techology thing but it all expands out
to fill up our entire culture so you
know newspapers will write the word she
I was speaking to a journalist the other
day and I was like why do you go a
picture of a big scraggly bearded man
with a Weg on and say woman arrested and
charged with um sex offenses she will be
sent you know like why do you do that
and they say it's just easier for the
sub editors to do it because if someone
doesn't write she then you're going to
get a complaint from someone else going
be says a woman you know and it it it
broadens out and out and out and out and
out and affects our culture and I think
I've just rambled into my myself into a
corner what was I trying to say no you
were talking about the the broadcast
ecology yeah so the broadcas so
separating out offc Comm is right why is
off Communists the off Communists which
is what they are essentially anything
with Cal on the end of it is Comm they
just stands for communism elcom we get
elcom the reclaimed party ELC communist
we get fined um investigated
relentlessly nonstop unlike any other
political party where and we're tiny
like this you know so I think there's a
determined effort not only to shut down
GB news but I think there's a determined
effort to shut down anyone who is
confident and okay to share an opinion
the the thing that I find really
frustrating when it comes to
broadcasters like the BBC so I actually
watched that news night all those people
around that table agreed they all agreed
that they probably broke ofcom rules
absolutely broke ofcom rules because
there was not one single person there
who offered a enting voice GB news has
Aaron bastani come on who we've had on
the show love Aaron Aaron is so far to
the left you can't you can't see him
right okay he's he's ah head of Navara
media is he as far to left as the
conservative
party it's a good point and a good joke
so you go you are not even adhering to
your own rules where you talk about the
fact that GB news is biased and doesn't
you know and it's it only has one point
of view but look at what you do but yet
that's seen as fine that's what angers
me yeah and I think the I think probably
the point I was trying to make is it's
not really an anger at GB news it's more
like going guys do you realize what is
about to happen you're going to have to
become afcom compliant which means you
have to become part of the
ecology you know and that means you're
just going to be the same as all of the
other channels their desperate last move
to not get removed is to become exactly
the same as Sky News or BBC News or ITV
News just with no budget no advertisers
it's like you just go out there with
swords and go no ofcom we're going to do
this we're going to fight you then they
are going to get shut down yeah
well this maybe this is why you don't
run a TV channel laen I don't want to
run I would never want to run a TV
channel yeah but I just don't think I
think ofcom what's the point of ofcom
just it's just narrative gatekeeping
look I become more and more sympathetic
to that position where watching what has
actually happened I mean are you worried
for GB news if you were if you were
working for them would you be worried I
mean you you still are um currently for
the next however long I've got the
disciplinary at two so um we'll see um I
am yeah I am I don't I'm not sure how
they can survive they you know again
this thing of about saying we're the
home of Free Speech but we to cancel a
load of people that's not a good look
for for a TV channel because it's their
USP I think that's a problem for them I
think that they'll have to dumb
themselves down so dramatically that
they'll become indistinguishable from
any other news channel and I think their
presenters will all be so have all their
authenticity taken away from them that
they'll just have to sort of say this
sort of same thing with a very slight
right leaning tendency you know and but
also they burnt a lot of bridges now
with you know they just suspended Calvin
Robinson for not going on someone's show
because he's trying to he's saying Dan
won hasn't been sacked yet or may not be
sacked at all so until that
investigation is complete I'm not going
to go on someone else's show because I
would feel that that would personally
compromise my loyalty to him as a person
it's the it's the guilty until proven
innocent thing which is um you know we
which is a much bigger problem in
society as we know not to make this more
of a struggle session but do you feel
responsible for what's happening to GB
news now are you quite happy that you've
sort of highlighted this issue how do
you feel about it no I don't I'm pissed
off with myself for for that um I I have
I I didn't I don't have any malevolence
towards GB news um I was I really
enjoyed going on and pursuing the
stories that I managed to get out and
certainly with the you know just
recently with the sadisco thales's
family and all of that sort stuff I
really I thought this is great this is a
channel that's talking about this um
look I I think that they've
jumped too am I responsible I am in a
way because look where's it come from
but am I responsible for saying what I
said no I'm responsible because they
took me I'm the bait I said the stupid
thing and the entire social media and
media descended on me but no Lawrence
but I come back to this point which I
think is important for this discussion
not to try and make you look better or
anything but they had to sack you I I
get that I get I'm not saying that
you're missing my I'm misund understand
I've said that several times they came
for me all of them and as you quite
rightly pointed out this is rank
hypocrisy from the from the media
ecology they came for me and they came
on mass so yes I am responsible but what
should GB news do when when that happens
you said something unacceptable that
breaks the rules both theirs and off
all these people come for you as you say
I I agree with you massive overreaction
even though your comments were wrong in
my opinion but what should GB news do in
that situation I don't know I think they
probably don't have much option I don't
know why they sus I don't know why they
suspended Dan nor do I actually um but I
think you know Dan's had some problems
there uh with with people trying to take
him down I don't know why they've
suspended Calvin this morning I don't
know why you know it's like uh I think
there's a you know I think there's just
there must be somewhere in a big room
somewhere they're going look we're
losing £30 million a year we need to get
some
advertisers we're going to need to Dum
this whole thing down make it
very you know advertising mainstream
yeah which is fine also do it but don't
hire
me I mean that's good advice it's like
they know what I'm like they know what
I've done what I've said and how open I
am with what I what I speak they tired
me I take full responsibility for what I
said and I fully support their right to
fight me I'm not trying to also I'm
really not interested in uh protecting
my job for the reasons I've already laid
out about the atmosphere in the place
anyway but um they did hire me and they
did know that you are you're hiring
someone who's on the edge and as Angelos
himself said sailes pretty close to the
wind on what is what is Free Speech now
if free speech is your passion and your
interest and you see it is the only way
out of a problem that we've got in in
culture then you are going to step on
landmines when you do it in the way that
I do it I'm constantly looking for where
what the edge of acceptability is and
I've troen over it and so be it bye I
you know I've
got I'm not it's not I'm not sitting
here going it's so unfair I'm not like
that it's not I don't I own my mistakes
Lawrence do you think as well I think
it's very interesting if you cast your
mind back to literally a week these
broadcasters particularly Channel 4 and
BBC were under heavy fire because of the
russal brand allegations heavy fire and
a lot of very difficult and important
questions were being asked about the way
that these broadcasters conducted
themselves and also how their presenters
conducted themselves and whether people
were being put in danger around these
presenters all of a sudden this blows
up they then come after GB news and look
maybe it's me being heavily
conspiratorial I'm here going is this
just a massive deflection tactic yeah of
course it is and also that as someone
quite rightly points out the only time
I've laughed um since Monday was someone
said hang on a minute everyone's being
in such a fuss for someone shagging too
many people and you're getting cancelled
for not wanting to Shag someone one
that's what they're against evil um yeah
you know they but the knives have been
out for GB news from day one even from
within the organization man there's
loads of people in there who hate that
channel and want to take it down why
they working there because they people
need money you know and they you're
trained out of Technical College or
you're trained by the BBC or whatever
and you don't get a job and you move and
get GB news and whatever Lawrence you
know what worries me about this whole
situation is IR respect of how crash and
the fence of your comments were whatever
we've got to a point where I think a
very significant portion of our
chattering classes care more about
people's words than about their
actions and that I I don't how I don't I
don't get that what it's easier to care
about someone's words if if someone says
the right thing it's like you know like
critical race Theory it's so much harder
to solve um actual inequalities in
society than just by saying well well if
you're black you you're you're oppressed
rather than going well no actually if
you're poor and you can't afford to feed
your own family you're oppressed by a
system which needs to be reformed um the
difficulty is yeah we we we we celebrate
false virtue that's one of the most
important um aspects of the modern uh
Progressive world that we live in um and
we and we we don't look at people's
actions I'm actually fairly I'm proud of
a lot of what I've done and I'm proud of
of a lot of the relationships that I
have people who profoundly disagree with
me and I've built Bridges where Bridges
cannot be built I suppose the worrying
part now is um I'm going to have to
leave the UK I think that's the my main
concern is like you're I'm cancelled for
my own country or why do you have to
leave the UK well well I've got to earn
a living I've got two kids to put
through school and to feed you know so
that's I think what'll have to happen I
mean do you think I should I mean I'm
really happy to nip over to um talk to
TV and knock on the door and go hey
guys anyone hiring you know I mean they
need the views loss they do to be fair
mate yeah I mean do do you think it's
really that bad or is this you know is
this going to I've been cancelled twice
man I've had my acting career taken away
from me for saying something totally
nothing wrong M you know so yes I've
gone over the we've done that bit um but
I had my acting career removed from for
saying that England is a tolerant warm
welcoming Nation so I've been cancelled
once that's and I had to drag myself up
with actually you helped me put together
a patreon and all that sort stuff how
you do it dragg myself back up out of um
out of that one and finally got back to
a position and then I'm canceled again
so I know how hard it is to pick
yourself up from these situations so you
know I'm not I don't know if I've got
the energy for it if I'm honest maybe
I'll be on the male suicide list you
know
I mean look but as well Lawrence you're
very charismatic you're a great
presenter you're incredibly likable
you've got a huge audience you've got a
lot of people who love what you do
you're very employable M it's true I'm
not saying none of these things that I'm
saying are wrong or incorrect there's a
lot of people who would look at you and
think to themselves yeah I would shank
him yes
exactly you can tell went to boarding
school mate I'm taken mate I'm I'm
afraid it depends how much you want the
gig Lawrence
yeah yeah it's actually the casting
couch bring it back I'll be killing all
well look man I I will say this and I I
don't like the joke you made about being
on the male suicide list because I
think I wasn't joking I know you weren't
and this is why this is why I don't like
it because I think I don't like that we
I'll say it again so this can't be
clipped out of contest I didn't agree
with what you said I didn't like what
you said but I don't like living in a
society where making a crash comment
puts you in this position no we should
that's not right no that's not right
when I was talking about it like when I
went to it last time those thoughts did
go through my head so you're like you
know what what's next what's coming next
and totally accept my insid fault as
well but we shouldn't live in a society
that does that that does that to people
and we
also we're talking principles rather
than Regulators we should not live in a
society where your only chance of
survival and existence is to count out
and bow to the whims of a councel mob
that will want to eat you regardless of
what you've got to say if it doesn't
agree with whatever the mob's mood is
that day that is a terrifying place for
society to be and I will say this as
well I think with Ava who made the
comments about male suicide which I
think were you know grotesque and
unacceptable she's probably got a lot of
[__] and that really shouldn't be
happening either you know both both you
and her should be in a position where
you express opinion that lots of other
people don't like but this idea that we
just gang up on people and we just spout
[__] at them until they want to go and
kill I don't gang up on anybody I'm not
saying you no no I'm just saying this is
why I hate that side of the argument and
I hate the ideology that she represents
because it's disgustingly vile divisive
and hateful and it supports the
cancellation of people the number of
people that come onto my feed and go
you're [__] you're [__] mate you're
dead it's over you know it's it's like I
would never do that to someone one you
wouldn't but I imagine she's had a lot
of people do that to her well and she's
been talked about how much it is so I
don't bother wasting my time it pretty
much going through the replies to my
feed because a lot of them are like uh I
hope your kids die I hope you die watch
your back you'll get St I I don't bother
to go for the victim thing because I
don't believe in victims I believe in
courageous people I admire courage and
um therefore it it is pretty bad so we
it's a complex situation we can agree
that what I said was wrong we can then
think about what should the consequences
of that be now I would I'm totally happy
to go right you're right I went past
your editorial code goodbye leave but
that
means for the second time that I where
am I going to get a job in the UK what
am I going to do you know and that is
when you're a father and most of the
stuff I do anyway the reason I spoke out
in the first place which was on
trigonometry ironically uh in 20
whenever 2019 2019 was to say this world
is in a really bad place and I've got
children and I don't want them to grow
up I need to do some of the fighting so
I don't leave them to have to do the
fighting I have half an hour
conversation with one of my son's uh psh
coordinators he was saying I was saying
said we don't teach uh extreme
ideologies and I said like what uh like
trans and stuff cuz that's an extreme
ideology isn't it and she oh no we teach
that and I said White Privilege do you
teach that and they're like yep pronouns
yep social transitioning something like
those are all extreme ideologies I'm
fighting my ass off to make sure that my
kid can leave school not totally part of
the medeia ecology or the cultural
ecology you know with the most important
thing in this world is that people are
themselves and we living in a culture
that is making people being yourself
contingent on the fact that you don't
have a job you don't have a livelihood
and it's game over should you [__] up
even once but Lawrence I I will sorry
before you do that I'll just say uh I
want uh our audience to get a chance to
say uh ask a few questions and and chip
in here so uh send in your questions now
uh we're going to go to a quick break
shortly after Francis asked a few
questions and we'll be answering your
questions and putting them to Lawrence
as well look I I think it's very
important at this point for everybody
who's watching and listen listening who
is in a situation where they feel that
they are without hope and this is
extended to you that there is always
hope Lawrence I know when things seem at
their most
Bleak is sometimes the moment or
frequently the moment where things can
turn around you're blessed when you're
at the end of your rope yeah I know it
very good it's just you know if you've
had two 48 Hours of every single popup
on your phone every single media channel
every
aimed at you yes and how evil you are it
makes you very very raw yeah so look
let's also talk about this as well
because this is an important part of the
discussion we've done the rest of it
what is it like being in the center of
this media storm right now um well you
you can't eat you thrive on cortisol so
it's like being you're you can see me
I'm itching it's very itchy you feel
hopeless very painful and you
feel you know you can't really you can't
feel sorry for yourself because your own
[__] thing you you've done it so it's
not that um you just feel I feel you I
get upset
about a little bit upset about the
hypocrisy of it all I suppose but it's
not surprised you know that's the nature
of these things it's horrible who would
want to live in it you know it makes you
want to a small lck cabin in a Feld
somewhere in Norway and write a long
James joycees type book for the next 15
years and wait for Britain to rot you
know and then see what happens and and
what effect does it had on the people
around you and your kids um my poor kids
are amazing but they they know who I am
they know what version of they know who
I am so they they're not going to
believe stuff that they say in the media
my sons are amazing um you know people
outside of that situation will use it to
weaponize there's a there's a very
famous actor went up to my son at school
and told him he was his dad was a
fascist you know which I think is about
a repellent Behavior as
possible but yeah no my family affects
my family it affects it affects
everybody you know that's what it does
it's uh but I I you know yet again
regardless of what of this current uh
issue there has been a Target on my back
for four years yeah and and that Target
is not going anywhere it's getting
sharper harder people are zooming in on
it and you know thank God I'm not a sort
of rapy person because they can't you
know I was like when are the next when
when do the sexual abuse allegations
come in next do they you know this this
lack of truth if you if you're not
watching a process take place honestly
like the Russell Brand thing was not
honest the way they went about that and
I I don't even like Russell Brown I find
him an irritating man if I'm really
honest um but you could see levers were
pulled machines were set in motion and
all of it what you mean well where were
the police if you've got a problem and
you've been sexually abused and raped
Lawrence it's not that simple mate no
but what it's not that simple what is
I'm not making it simple I'm turning
around and saying you before someone has
been formally charged with sexual
assault he's innocent and proven guilty
you do not have the culture minister or
whatever a stupid
name committee writing to people trying
to have completely that is Comm
communism well well you know it's it's
it's a it's a member of the committee
the chair of the committee she's an MP
for gosport this what do you think she's
completely unacceptable but that's what
I'm saying it demeans the problem that
they're trying to solve which is the
Under reporting and under conviction of
female sexual assault
so anyone who's got even the vaguest
level of of skeptical thought over a
government which has lied to us
relentlessy and Rel relent you're
feeding us so your point is that that
happening sort of like it it creates
more doubt in people's minds about The
credibility of the allegations exactly
which I agree with you entirely on and I
think it's slightly different to the
point about go to the police because it
is more complicated than that a lot of
we've spoken to people who've been
victims of sexual assault and a lot of
them will say you know it's my word
against his he's much more powerful all
of that stuff and I understand that
stuff I really do um but I think you
know Francis and I both agree with you
and we said it at the time that you know
these rumors about Russell Brand have
been going around in our industry for
over a decade so do you think and
Russell Brand is the tip of the iceberg
I worked with show business for 25 years
and as I've said before I could the
number of National Treasures I could
bury is beyond stuff you know and that's
not just that's not for things like
sexual and it's the same with Russell
Bry and comedy there's a lot of other
people that should have been in the
article yeah but weren't and I'm curious
to find out where that is well it's this
look it's like we've got a pro we got a
problem in the in the UK we got a major
major problem and and I don't think
people quite we've said we've talked
about it before but it's got steadily
worse to the point where you know
there's a legitimate reason for
sanctioning me but I think the level of
it will make some people think what is
as you said is there an ulterior motive
was there're like oh we can distract
from the BBC Russell brown stuff and
we'll just jump on GB news get Lawrence
done because that's what we do because
he's a blubber mouth and he says the
wrong thing
frequently um and it again it applies
skepticism and if this girl AA is
talking about uh you know sexual assault
and all of that sort of stuff
weaponizing words like I want men to be
terrified that that diminishes away from
the goal of of of what we all as a
society you must have girlfriends and
you must have girlfriends and I have
girlfriend I don't have girlfriends I'm
just married I know friends that are
girls who have experienced at the very
least unwanted sexual advances and at
the very worst much more yeah yeah so we
have to have a conversation as a society
how do we deal with that problem mhm one
of the ways of having that conversation
is to have a free and open conversation
about it you know and um I don't think
that the way the media have handled
Russell Brandon I don't think the word
she used on that show which you know I
know it's harder to get but she she does
use the word frightened terrified I
don't think that's going to this is a
talk TV discussion from last year with
Conor Tomas I don't think that's going
to make you know and and I know a lot of
men one of the other things is is not
talked about whereas men maybe use
sexual violence women will use
psychological violence against men they
will abduct children they will
completely remove children from their um
the father's life and Father's again
will commit suicide as a as a result of
it which Jeff noot wanted to talk about
in a balanced Fairway but no the the
medeor ecology or the broadcasting
ecology you're not allowed to talk about
that we got to talk about how bad it is
for girls all right Lawrence we've done
an hour's interview and I really want
our audience to have their say I have no
idea what they think of what you're
saying of what we're saying and I
actually think it's really important to
get them involved so we're going to take
a break for a couple of minutes get you
another cup of water or whatever
uh and uh we'll we'll be back in a
couple of minutes with your questions
keep the super chats coming in we've got
some paypals as well we're going to be
reading out uh some of the best ones uh
we'll do about half an hour uh when we
come back see you in a couple of minutes
I need to take a
w I only applied to Cambridge got into
Cambridge and I thought that was going
to be the beginning of my full agency it
was actually the beginning of the end I
suddenly was exposed to sort of a
culture
of critical theories which told me that
I was a victim and that I was at an
inherent
disadvantage and that really messed with
my mind I got very depressed was an
anti-depressant was suicidal for my
second year through my life it was white
people who cared for me it was white
people who loved me i' had been
abandoned by my black mother so there
was an inherent contradiction in what I
was being told you're a young woman who
is at Cambridge University you get a
degree from there your opportunities are
Limitless and yet you're a victim with
it I mean it's it's it's just bollocks
[Music]
this kind of pessimistic narrative which
we've mostly imported from America is
simply inconsistent with
reality I think it's um indicative of a
wider problem at the moment in terms of
culture America is the metropo and the
UK is basically a colony there's this
phrase uh that again we borrow from
America which is this is a country built
a nation of immigrants and I've read
British history it's not a nation of
immigrants it's not why do we do that um
I I think the reason why we do that is
because we sort of don't want to concede
any point to the sort of anti-immigrant
conservative or far right whatever you
want to call them but I think the best
way to do that is to do it on on the
basis of Truth yeah rather than on the
basis of any sort of myth making if you
tell people um enough times that they
are the victims of racism they are the
victims of Oppression they are the
victims of
discrimination they will inevitably see
it
[Music]
everywhere
hello and welcome back to our exclusive
live interview with Lawrence Fox this is
the segment where you get to ask your
questions to Lawrence so make sure to
send through a PayPal or a Super Chat
and we'll put your questions to Lawrence
himself before we go into the questions
will say you were very on brand right as
we finished the interview before we cut
off you went I need a w and stood up and
that is the last thing that people Sor
that's absolutely that is absolutely
fine don't fire me I don't want to
breach your and plus that is the sort of
stuff that we do here anyway sa and high
like Eagle sending a Super Chat says how
do you maintain the stability of your
sons during this turbulent time are
there many mates supporting you
personally too do attacks like this give
you more courage to fight on uh very
good question um my children are you
know your kids as you know as any father
knows they are a lot of your reason for
living so I do what I always do which is
I make a family dinner every night when
they get back from school and you know
they have breakfast by themselves
because they're grumpy little bastards
and but when they get back from school I
make them a homemade meal every night
and we sit down and we talk through
issues and you know what you got to do
when you're going through something like
this is give out to your children so
don't go into yourself uh on you know
when I've had the these before my little
ones come up and said you're right Dad
and you don't really want that from your
kids so you want to I'm like how was
your day and you distract out of it um
I've had I'm very blessed with an
amazing woman who is really um
supporting me which has been great and
some really good friends you know it's
uh I mean it's great the situations like
these are great friend color
moments so um you we get to go around
and C again but I've you know I'm I'm my
life is hugely blessed really so I you
know I've got my health and I've got my
kids and I've got love so that's all
that matters really absolutely uh
Richard E asks Lawrence what are your
plans for the
future I don't know man I'm not sure I'm
doing a lot of the the law our legal
stuff we're going to take the Department
of Education to court to stop the I mean
they've already the government are
starting to come around on uh onto our
ideas um but we've got a lot a lot of
families of kids who've been socially
transitioned then moved on uh to the
full transitioning and being regretted
the the full stuff and you know we we
want the Department of Education to lay
out some very clear guidance or just
even possibly uphold the existing one
and stop the uh you know teachers well
activists that were formerly known as
teachers um in indoctrinating our
children with this same mind rubbish
that's filling up the rest of the
society embl says not a question just to
say that most women fully support Men's
Health especially mental health being
given due attention which I think is
objectively just true yeah and she says
I appreciated Lawrence's apology it felt
sincere and thoughtful what a [__] show
this all is yeah I think that's the
truth it is a [__] show and that's very
very sad and I do feel you know actually
I do feel really sad that I've put GB
news is in this position where they're
now sort of Desperately canceling
everybody um and they Angelos certainly
has been never been anything other than
a gentleman really Charming to me so I
you know it is a reciprocal relationship
and I do I have let them down in that
way which is why I apologized yesterday
because I wanted to I wasn't apologizing
because I don't I'm not trying to say
please can have my job I'm not all I'm
apologizing because I have my own
conscience which leads on to this idea
which I actually we touched on last time
which is if we've got two sides of an
ever increasing
tribalism which won't speak to each
other you're going to have a fight at
some point and this is the skirmishes
that going on at the moment you know
we'll cancel them get rid of them but
that become it will become physical one
day so part of being a Christian is also
to forgive and you can't forgive unless
you ask for repentance you know and so
that was what the point of my video was
was to say genuinely to her so she
understood that it was totally genuine
that I apologize for the way I spoke to
her whilst not apologizing for the
sentiment behind what I spoke and I
believe that the
world if we lived in a in a more
forgiving world then where forgiveness
was was upheld as a real value was was
sexy was cool yeah rather than
counseling it which is cool well this is
why we wanted to have you on and have
this discussion uh actually and in terms
of the tribes fighting it's it's what we
are trying to do here which what we've
always tried to do and that's why you
know we had Aaron bastani on recently
and Mark steel and I I did a debate on
the moral maze with Ash Saka she will
come on when she's got a book out we
want to bring people together and have
really good healthy conversations uh and
do them like this where you get to see
the whole person you know you said some
some things that people will disagree
with and I disagree with but you're also
a great guy and you know when I've been
around your kids you're a great dad and
you are like all of us a rounded human
being who's fallible makes mistakes
lives on the edge as you say and
sometimes you do go too far and you and
I have had our private disagreements on
whatever but you know I I I think it's
really important to humanize each other
in that way I really do I agree with you
I think we um if we you know we we lose
Humanity if we don't oh absolutely I'm
not really getting a lot of uh messages
through I've only had two through but I
will this is one message that I've got
through that is not a question well it
kind of is actually it's from richardy
law Lawrence Fox is a freedom fighter
for free speech hopefully he will start
his own platform question mark yeah well
I'll have to do something because
literally I've got to feed children and
um this is that that when you as a man
you know again going back to the idea of
man and women I'm sure as well but the
first thing a man thinks is like how am
I going to feed my kids yep I'm pretty
sure that's what women think as well I
did say I was just joking but in a in a
um if you're in a marriage or something
like that then you know sometimes it's
not the end of the world but if you're a
doing what I do which is I'm pretty busy
all the time I have a lot of structural
support around my life to make sure that
I can provide my kids with the time that
they need and you know and everything
that they need to do because that's the
that they are the most important thing
so yeah I think I probably will I I
don't know I'll I'll have to work out
what to do yeah I mean you know got a
few million people watch my thing
yesterday mying including musk yeah Matt
Shaw says uh sadik Khan spends millions
of public money on his May campaign
what's he got to say about suicide
number one cause of death among men
under 50 uh nothing doesn't care nobody
does well if we convince Sadi Khan that
suicide in men men under 50 was caused
by climate change I'm sure' I'm sure
he'd be really involved but I again you
know if you think about it are men like
is the feminization of men helping them
not it's not men need to go like I'm
lucky because I was raised to be
expressive I mean unlucky in situations
as well but I I do tell people how I
feel so if I felt really desperate I
think I would tell someone but I've got
so many people I know who just wouldn't
and that you get the
call and it's just heartbreaking and you
you go you're a friend and you're like
why didn't I see it why couldn't I
spotted it why didn't I say anything why
and I say to someone that they knew that
I was worried or you know because we're
and I don't think any of this is going
to help cocking men sorry no no I don't
I also don't think men talking about
their feelings is necessarily the answer
to all of this I think for men the
answer is uh doing things you love
solving whatever problems are causing
you to be unhappy whe whether that is
through you know therapy or whatever but
it shouldn't be like oh I feel bad oh
really we're so sorry you should
actually help you overcome the issues
that you're dealing with exercise you
know like I worked out in my late 20s
how to give myself depression in a week
flat how just to me mate talking to
Francis just hang around with him just
talk to me mate no but well yeah he'll
do that in less than a week but uh don't
get enough sleep yeah drink alcohol or
take drugs uh stay indoors don't
exercise don't talk to anyone don't
speak to family and friends and whatever
you do that for a week I don't care how
great your brain is you're going to feel
pretty depressed so I work worked out
how to feel better like the weather
turned like a week ago and I was
instantly like whoa I can feel so I was
like okay well I need to up my exercise
I need to call my family I need to do
this I need to do that I need to spend
more time with my son and wife all of
that that really is the answer I think
for men instead of like oh let's sit
down and talk men don't want to talk
about our feelings it's just not how
we're built we're not wired that way
you're right but I I think we're talking
slight different things which is it's
the permission to yeah uh it's the
permit you you're exactly right I've had
this neck operation I haven't been able
to exercise for eight months it's
completely messed with my my I was
running in and out of the office every
day I was you know it was I was feeling
good I gave up smoking and then I met a
doctor who said to me why are you vaping
that's even worse than smoking get
smoking or give up everything yeah and
you it's had a real profound effects I'm
a very much a doer person you know I do
and I get out and I do things and I'm
busy and I and I think that's right you
can't just sit and listen to people moan
but I think if a man or or a woman or I
don't think it really should be about
sex if someone is feeling desperate and
sad they tend to go quiet they tend not
to go noisy yeah and that's you know
that's what I've noticed yeah absolutely
uh Alan says don't remember anyone
suggesting the BBC getting X when brand
and Ross made their shagged your
granddaughter comments well it's but
also at the end of the day that was very
distasteful but it was sort of an
attempt at humor yeah in the same way as
my I wouldn't shag that was an attempt
at humor yeah so we've also got to
remember that the first thing the the
the sunlight to the woke vampire is
laughter yeah and you know we're going
to f I wrote it my song first four was
laughter just to quell the unoffended it
was a beautiful song by the way sha T
says and you know we've talked about GB
news quite a bit and this is a
provocative question but he says serious
question following this what is now the
point of GB news uh very good question I
don't know because it's perception Isn't
It ultimately the USP of GB news is Free
Speech that's it home of free speech
that's what they said we're the home of
free speech now whether they still
maintain to be the home of free speech
as regulated by
ofcom you're not really the home of free
speech if you're the home of free speech
as regulated by ofcom I don't know why
GB news ever wanted to be regulated
anyway they have explained it to me
several times but I'm like imagine you
can't broadcast on TV they should have
just gone online he should just been an
online Channel which I think they're
going to do um I don't know what the
future of GB news is I think the way
that they've
um behaved certainly over Dan and Calvin
is um it's not Dan's fault if you found
something I say funny is it yeah and he
did actually say you know just to
provide balance I mean look he probably
should have pushed back a lot stronger
but he was laughing that was the point
people make mistakes too yeah every but
that's it everyone makes mistakes but
the problem is is if you make mistakes
on GB news it's game over yeah well like
I said I think sacking you is what they
have to do I don't understand why they
would sack Dan and and the I haven't had
a chance to look into the Calvin
situation properly no they you know
we'll we'll see what happens Esther says
you can be forthright Lawrence without
being course IE Douglas Murray yes you
can you can absolutely but fortunately
my name is Lawrence and my son name is
Fox not muray uh Ralph 89 says would
there be any possibility of La of
Lawrence joining one of the existing
alternative media networks um which are
what what are they like Lotus Eaters Etc
I'll speak to I'm sure I'll speak I'll
probably just start I'll start one up
I'll just turn around and go you know
just go around turn around and say you
know let's use the money that we use for
this for that you know we we'll we'll
we'll see I've always said from the day
I started off doing claim party I said I
don't think the political part is the
right answer cuz I don't think there's a
political solution to a cultural problem
therefore you need a cultural solution
to the problem which is which is to make
yeah even if it's stupid as saying being
a m is cool you know make make being a m
cool again instead of teaching all of
these poor little girls and young women
who are coming out of school that the
only way that they can ever be truly
respected in life is by not having
children and biger having more money
than men it's like well really you're
going to really regret that decision at
38 when your fertility falls off the
cliff I mean it's very true it's very
true M says apart from anything were
some GB news presenters naive to think
it would be a paragon of free speech
when they played in MSM territory uh
mainstream media territory and put
themselves under ofcom not the GB news
can't be a better MSM um yeah I I I
think I'm very guilty of the you know
they sent me their broadcast it's
Charter and all that sort of stuff and
I'm just like yeah whatever I get it say
what you think and then if someone don't
let someone you know allow someone to
disagree that was my Essential view of
it so you know again I'm think I think
I'm guilty podcast itis where you just
you know I just I I you know offc com is
just sort of some bunch of um censorship
drones who I don't want to ever speak to
or I don't think about when I'm at work
other people do that for me or
not I've got another one y go for Marco
says Mr Fox mistakes have been made uh
you've owned up to them and well done
you do have great points in general and
do good work lead by example and I wish
you luck thanks trig gang for the chance
to chip
in so um and match says Adam Bolton is a
fool whose career should have been ended
when he appeared drunk on TV with alist
Campell and lost his Rag and Campbell of
all people told him dignity dignity and
utter gargoyle well that's mata's
opinion yeah there you go I haven't seen
the Adam Bolton drunk on TV I've seen a
couple allegedly oh allegedly drunk on
TV I've seen a a couple of really funny
um drunk on TVs but my favorite drunk um
one is drunk referees in football have
you seen that no no oh just type inun
drunk referees in football best YouTube
video you ever seen in your life there
you go microft says just sending love to
Laurence nothing else so that's good
thank you and uh Jason says do you think
the latest form of feminism basically
Advocates a structural change to make
men subservient and subjugated to women
yeah it's authoritarian feminism
absolutely 100% And it's so bad for both
sex is because you know there's a reason
why all of these I mean God I trying to
think about some of the stuff I used to
be taught at school and and you know
this stuff would be child abuse nowadays
you know you need good strong men to
lead and families and you know anyone
who said that nowadays is an outright
fascist antivaccine conspiracy theorist
it's why things like rugby and you know
contact sports are actually so important
particularly for boys so that when you
do get a punch in the head you you know
you get a shoulder and the ribs you
realize it's not the end of the world
it's just a bit of pain and you'll be
able to run it off I know but my little
my little one was T has been you know
goes to one of those you get free U
medals for coming
last and uh I was told at one football
match I wasn't allowed to clap if they
scored and then um my and they
indoctrinate children with it so then he
comes home and he's like I it doesn't
matter about winning Dad it's just about
playing the game and I'm like okay do
you want to go me FIFA he's like yeah
and I just you know usually I let him
win uh and I just started beating him
and he just got more and more and more
and more angry and I said do you know
that feeling hold on to that cuz that's
competitiveness and then did you score
another goal after
that if you're going to if you're going
to destroy a child's confidence you must
do it totally utle yeah AB 7 nil
Mansfield Town versus Man United Julia
says uh Laurence set up your own YouTube
channel we need to hear your voice we
need to hear your opinions too I'm a
psychiatric nurse and you're bang on
about male suicide thank you for trying
to help Julia yeah my in my inbox if you
could read the inbox of my Twitter feed
of messages from women who whose
husbands or Partners or children have
killed themselves you that's why I got
so upset again at the beginning because
I've been reading them all day yeah I
just yeah yeah yeah yeah and Jamie says
will this damage their reclaim party um
know Dam I mean I'm mean I I don't know
I think it's hard to argue that this W
but yeah yeah not not that I take any
pleasure in that of course but yeah I
think that's it Lawrence thank you for
coming back listen before we should say
this right before we leave which is
you're going through a rough time uh we
may not always agree with you but you're
a friend and please always call us when
you're going through difficult stuff
whatever is going on you should remember
there's a lot of people who like you and
love you and support you even when you
make mistakes as you did in this case
and all of that aside so please look
after yourself look after your family uh
and all the best to you and I said this
is equally true of anybody else
including AA we wish everybody the best
even if they're wrong even if they say
things that are wrong even if they're on
the other side of politics or whatever
we need more healthy discussion and we
need more healthy conversation so thank
you for being here thank you for coming
on and talking to us uh I hope this has
been productive for everybody and you
and us and everybody included yeah my
pleasure thank you I'm just off to
destroy someone on Twitter man
take care guys we'll see you later on
bye